so christopher i'll come to you first
with this uh the end result with the
design work on neverland looks
absolutely incredible but can you give
me i guess one benefit and one challenge
of having to play a character that
requires you to be in such extensive
makeup and prosthetic work
well i can give you 99 obstacles
well uh i had seven people around me at
all times to to to make the the suit
work uh every
to help me in and out and to help me
with the camera i had in my face all the
time and the sound and i had a
movement coach with me because if if we
didn't use the the suit right it died so
it had to be like to keep it alive
uh
uh we had to like
play play play the suit you know uh so
it was warm uh it was sweaty
but
the nice thing was that i couldn't get
out of character because when i was in
the suit i had to be the suit you know
so so in that way it helped them a lot
it was well worth it it looks incredible
i love hearing about
like movie magic that we would think be
would be really complicated but is
actually a really simple thing behind
the scenes so can you paint a picture of
what it looked like when things dropped
into frame that didn't require vfx is it
literally just somebody else behind the
scenes dropping food and knives and
whatnot into frame above you
no that was real magic i can do that
if
you like to like this you know things
fall
i can do
[Laughter]
i need i need some of that magic in my
life i could use that right now
all right kim so
vesemir is like a father figure to
gerald but since we the viewers met
geralt first in season one is there
anything that you saw in henry's
performance in that first season that
you were maybe able to apply to your own
now something that would emphasize that
much of what we saw in that first season
was taught to him by bessemer
yeah i i i loved his performing in the
first season
and and he was so integrated in
his part so i just stole everything i
was like i was like no for sure i did of
course because then i thought okay he
got it from his father you know
so the way he's talking
so i i really i was really trying to to
integrate all that in my my system and
it was very difficult to have seen
without henry because i couldn't hear
his voice so
so that's why i was out of balance i
really took uh the way he was
[Music]
talking and the way he's like
and
also the demons in him but but actually
henry wanted to go deeper into his
character
and wanted to find some emotional uh
expression that could be a part of
gary's life and that was wonderful to to
follow uh that journey he had there and
supporting was fantastic
it comes through really beautifully i
love that quality the second season it
was also reading that you were pretty
heavily involved in developing vesamir
sword and his overall look so are there
any small details that you played a part
in making happen that you really hope
viewers don't miss
i think i think the most important thing
is that that the way
i had to move like we were hearing about
the other costumes that i was had to
create it from a person living in the
nature all the time and had to survive
in nature so all the all the way we
built up the stuff around him was that
he had to move around very easily and
and have to survive everything
so and so it has to feel natural it has
to fall on the body like natural nothing
has to be you know sitting wrong or
be
but i i think when people have watched
the game and then they really understand
uh the costume so so i think i think
they will see everything
all right i want to put up the spoiler
warning right now so you guys could talk
freely about these next two questions
but
christopher i'm curious to get your
opinion on where neville ends at the end
of that episode do you view it as a
complete loss of hope he is doomed he is
essentially going to do exactly what he
asked geralt to do or like is there is
there any kind of light at the end of
the tunnel where he could learn from his
mistakes and move forward
well i believe that
we are able to change and i think he has
gone a long way
in his remorse uh
for the deeds he done
so i i believe that he can
come back from that uh and i don't think
he has the courage to to kill himself so
so i i i believe
in him
even without the beard
all right my spoiler question for you
now kim
i
want to know if you could tell me a
little bit about the scene where vesimir
commits to giving siri the mutagen do
you think that you know he truly deep
down believed that she would survive or
has he become just totally blinded by
the eagerness to rebuild witchers
you're so right it's so complex i'm
still working on it it's like oh god
it's like it's awful i mean
you're totally right and that is exactly
the complex inside with me right now and
i have no idea where it's going with
that painfulness to to sacrifice and and
and go into that mindset and you know i
can lose my own son i mean i can lose
her i can lose everything just to
to keep on going with creating more
witchers man oh it's it's tough it's
very tough i'm still working on and
still you know it's been stolen from me
also you know so now
the pain inside visimir is more not that
i was
i was going in that world but i'm
covered in and trying to get that mutant
back
between you and freya i could have
watched that scene play out for a full
hour just to keep looking for the cracks
into seeing the wheels and your heads
turning because
it feels especially complex and i love
digging into beats like that they're
gonna kick me out of here thank you guys
so much for your time huge
congratulations on the show thank you so
much